Ah, my name, even in a country, as lousy with artists as France,
he has secured himself a position as one of the grandmasters, a painting,
even if the thicker winds of public rewards were inconsistent in his life.
You may know,
known as the dude who painted Meadows and skylines in unexpected colors,
but to millions of adoring museum goers,
he is a bigger rock star now than at any point in his life.
And just like a rock star,
his name can be found on every these of merchandise imaginable, jewelry ties,
scarves apron, stuffed frogs finger puppets, children's books, Prince pop-up,
garden models.
Even the occasional hand painted reproduction experts in the know agree.
Monet is money 2019 saw a new all-time record for
most expensive money ever sold $110 million for a version of haystacks,
which had been held in private ownerships and just completion in the art
collecting world pieces by a Monet are extremely popular because of their ever
appreciating value and the frequency with which they show up at auction is
reported to have painted over 2000 canvases in his life.
Often working on multiple iterations of the same subject simultaneously to best
capture specific moments of light and color because the work is so consistent,
it becomes easier for appraisers to value paintings by comparing them to the
sale of prices of works from the same set. Also Manet's paintings are gorgeous.
Now we say that about every artist we feature,
but Manet more than most knew how to convey emotion through the raw medium of
color,
how to play light against itself in a ballet of feeling Monet is the strongest
arguments against photo realism.
Art that can be made the idea that a painting can depict de subjective
impression over a concrete reality was such a fundamental rejection of the
autistic trends of the era. That's even the label.
Impressionism was first intended as a critique.
The paintings were considered incomplete,
rudimentary sketches of scenes rather than the fully realized some.
She was visual feasts that they are beneath the gardens,
the pastorial picnic ready Meadows,
the cultivated capitalistic Steria beat the hot of an unstoppable
revolutionary Medan.
His contemporaries represented such a vast departure from the artistic
establishment that 20 temporary relocated to the Netherlands.
The police secretly investigated them for political sedition,
the bad and painted landscapes. It's someone confused them.
The maps credit goes to the indispensable book wizards at the university of
Massachusetts Amherst libraries collection,
who succeeded in tracking down copies and translations of the actual
surveillance nodes kept by the police today may well be the first time they're
ever seen on YouTube. So I believe him.
And I tell you that this is a bit of a special episode.
Everyone is born a genius.
It's what we do with the intervening years that decides if we get to keep the
title Monet's genius. First blessed Paris on the 14th of November,
1840 son of a merchant and singer,
it was assumed young Oscar would follow his father into the families' ship
channeling business.
Fortunately for us art quick primer and obscure Naval trivialities
Chandler is basically a petrol station, but for sailboats,
fewer gummy worms and dodgy meat pies,
more whale grease and hook hands it's far from glamorous walk.
Most of your clients being Cutlass wielding, weevil, eating privateers,
but will buy enough needlessly long breads to feed a family.
Anyone born into that kind of guaranteed comfort cause count themselves pretty
lucky in the 18 hundreds. So of course, Monet pursued art with his mind,
body and soul. At the age of 11,
he had already established himself as a caricature artist.
After his family moved to Normandy,
he would sit in the town square with a stack of papers and some charcoal and
sell sketches for 10 to 20 Franks Paul at the age of again,
11 as a mother,
I believed in her son unconditionally as brothers all want to do,
but she died when he was barely 16, rather than bachelor.
During his up with his blubber Munger of a father,
he went to live with his Chandler's widowed aunt.
It'd be easy to make jokes about her as a veil cloud,
Mona's wanting through a dusty gray garden style estate or a Whalebone corset,
a Dickensian governance, but in all seriousness though,
name may owe his life to Maria.
It makes you 61. Monet was drafted into service. We as chefs,
sewer to our free cavalry group comprised of equal parts,
French youth and locally recruited North African soldiers, fun fact,
six years before it was drafting,
they were involved in the famously failed charge of the light brigade,
which we'll probably talk about in a future video.
Let's pretend you're a wealthy Lund elder of the channeling community that
sweat of your brow has purchased your family,
a comfortable life in an upcoming city.
Your only son is looking at a 70th stints of getting shot out in a desert that
hates them.
So naturally you'll use some of your hard earned money to buy his freedom,
right? Well, congratulations. You're a better father than Manet hat puppet.
Claude refused to spare his son from military service because his son would not
renounce art in favor of ship genre.
It's like very PESI imagine seeing your child you off almost exclusively for the
entirety of their lives,
then refusing to spare them from an almost decade long sentence.
Even in the extremely crowded field of terrible fathers of influential artists,
clawed at all for Monet manages to stand out.
Thankfully geniuses never quaters during the occupation,
his skills did not go unnoticed after sketching some desert landscapes in a
bustling marketplace, Tableau, he was approached to do portraits of officers.
Sadly, none of these works survived to the modern age, but it's evidence.
How much of an impact traveling to Algeria?
Hands on his appreciation for striking visuals. Here is a biome.
Unlike anything France could ever produce sprawling deserts and glittering oases
with bazaars. We'll have people in totally new styles and colors of dress,
the food, the elaborate North African mosaic, tall work. He himself,
even at message. This,
all of this contains the gem of my future research is in color and form.
However, after two years in cramps,
Garrison Monet got down with that notorious typhoid fever.
For those of you, who've never read Dickens.
Typhoid can only be spread by consuming the feces or blood,
or they gross monster who didn't wash their hands. Good thing,
nothing like that happens in modern times.
Monet always died because someone didn't wash their hands at some point between
using the bathroom and cooking dinner or that kids don't be the person who
almost killed Manet, wash your filthy hands.
Thankfully rather than let them slowly die on a cart. His arms Murray John,
let God repetition.
The government do release him early in exchange for attending art lessons,
art school or military services, eight questions.
So obvious and straightforward, not even a parliamentarian,
good weasel their way out of the direct answers. So he graciously accepted.
So let this shock you,
but on occasion artists and their models have affairs Camille's you don't see
it. I got to live out that ultimate romance and a little fantasy muse wife to a
misunderstood genius, who parishes at a tragically beautiful age.
She was the model for many of his early works, including women in a green dress.
One of the first pieces do you hang in the famous Alonda Perry in the Japanese
she's portrayed as a blonde in a brilliant red kimono holding a fan.
This was a Santa Rona, Zen contemporary obsession with Japanese art.
And what will surely come as a surprise Camille's parents did not approve of the
courtroom marriage between the 20 five-year-old penniless artist and their 18
year old daughter. When they had that first child,
her parents disowned her though Monet had a few gallery showings money was hard
to come by and he wants to destroy it a canvas rather than let it be seized
about creditors in 1870 war in France,
drive money to England where he exhibited his work a few times to modest
commercial success. With these funds,
he was able to relocate his family to Zan dam Holland in early 1871.
The same year that the radical socialist experiments of the Paris commune was
crushed by French government forces.
They wrote in letters that he was fleeing France out of belief,
that one of his best friends,
they witnessed that his wedding had been shot without trial. In reality,
the man was dried and sentenced to six months in prison, but either way,
any French national traveling abroad was considered a potential political
refugee seen her if photocopies copies of the actual telegram reports,
the police sent to the Dutch government, the fairly brief,
because it turns out the money wasn't a secret radical socialist sent to
undermine Dutch society.
It was a painter and he spent most of his time painting.
One of the reasons Dutch authorities knew to expect him coming was due to the
media reputation. Monet had thus far cultivated.
He would be interviewed while painting storms or standing on the edge of
perilous cliffs. This would pay off years later in 1874,
when Monet and Renoir and the other impressionists held an unjudged gallery
exhibition in protest of the stuffy Salone to Perry.
Anyone could come off the streets and check out the new style,
including the infamous impression, sunrise, the work whose disparagement in spa,
the name impressionism in the first place. But we're getting out of ourselves
Regarding to parents in 1872 poverty compelled them to move frequently and they
would come to share a house with his former patrons,
Alison and his hot-seat also broke. Earnest,
stayed close to the city for work while Alice lived with them. And A's,
there were eight children in that house.
Even with two women doing all the housework, the economics were grim.
The situation went from bat to West.
Once Camille's health started to fail and 1876 afflicted with both tuberculosis
and uterine cancer. She died slowly over a period of years.
And I find a moment as Monet painted. One of his most controversial works.
Camille Monet upon her death bed.
The work itself is certainly a fitting tribute to the woman who had given my
niece so much only a faces visible over the bed sheets, but the whole figure,
it seems to be enveloped in this gentle gradient, like a veil,
the arch of the bed over her recalls the image of an Angel's wings.
The texture of the face draws the eye to the creases where her arms seem to be
folded over a chest, almost like a mummy.
The priest who administered her last rights also sanctioned the marriage between
them blessing.
What had started out as a simple civil ceremony those few years ago,
despite having just lost his wife and he did not stay single long.
He and Alice grew closer.
This rampant speculation that their affair started as soon as KML fell ill and
the press made sport of this even going so low as to mock the hardworking
owners, to continue to hustle,
to support the household while staying in Claude soul studio in Paris.
Imagine living that life, imagine financially supporting an artist,
letting him raise your children.
And while you try and restore your family's fortune and good name,
only for them to turn around and romance your wife while his own dime
Camille's death would see Monet hone his multiple canvas techniques,
switching to a new one every seven minutes while waiting for the panes on one
canvas to dry, he would immediately start work on another often up to 10 or 20.
At one time,
he is rumored to have once grown so overwhelmed by the scale he was working on
this. He pitched everything into a river only to fish it out moments later.
So let's talk about what made his work so different. Back then,
painting was a messy space and labor intensive process.
Artists would stretch their own canvases and make their own paints by grinding
pigments, into powders and mixing them with oils.
Things that much easier to do in a studio rather than on a hillside 10 miles
away because they were painting models in a controlled environment.
So lots of arts,
contemporary to Monet feel staged and artificial Brock near classical work
steeped in Greco. Roman mythology was what the art buying public wants.
It extremely nude gods wrapped in floating sheets.
That's what art was to the young Monet naked babies flying around the loop
ceiling. In case you thought I was kidding.
Apollo slaves plays them by Eugene Delacroix represents the absolute epitome of
what critics expected of artists at the time,
technically precise photo realistic depictions of mythological struggles.
This particular work was commissioned by Louis the 14th.
And it depicts a scene from overdose work metamorphosis where the God Apollo
wrestles some snaky fines. The work is rich and metaphors.
You can see everything on the bottom of the painting is dark and evil.
Looking while everything at the top is shiny and bright, very subtle,
the perfect subject to pontificate on while holding a snifter of Brandy.
Why is it important putting aside the fact that it's a palace ceiling,
the months and years of constant perpetual toil?
What impression does this painting leave on you?
Where does that feeling come from? Does it come from the high quality inks,
the hours the model spent posing for reference sketches,
all the assistants scurrying around Della CRA,
who gets to decide that this matters.
[Inaudible].
I think out of the studio realizing the inability of the imagination to grasp
the intricacies of nature was made much easier by a number of technical
developments, including the collapsible easel lends the shade box,
portable container for both paints and small canvases.
Suddenly anyone could step out into the light and dash off wax of natural genius
without needing a small retainer of handmaidens do tote your bags for you shall
Francois [inaudible] invented a fully stocked floating studio,
so he could easily drift down the sin and paint.
The shoreline effortlessly dashing off masterpiece often lost a piece because it
was suddenly accessible and almost democratized to a point.
This led to an explosion in this style of art. And it was this absolute fever,
the natural world that my niece stepped into as a young artist,
Bo Allah granary, Leah from 1869, a scene based on a floating restaurant,
which fellow impressionist Renoir also pains.
It it's a bigger group of Baders resting on a small Island next to a restaurant.
Everything surrounded by water rather than being just some plastic mirror.
The river itself is an active participant in the scene.
Instead of trying to recreate the exact images in the water may intersperse is
the same color of the foliage above with the blue of the water to create the
illusion of ripples here,
the bands denote both the surface and capacity of the water.
If you look close enough,
you can see the zigzags of Connor gradually breaking into secular Tonya spots,
not exactly a recreation of the surface of the water,
but it's an approximation of what it feels like.
We are invited to fill in the visual imperfections with our own emotional
reactions to the piece.
Take a look at how we use those colors to give the impression of shadow.
We know that this crowd is seated in the shade because of the contrast of the
brighter foliage behind them.
The line makes it look yellow while the closer leaves are a deep green,
the motion of the water throws back more light than the sky above it.
You seem trees wave in the wind before you instinctively know how to read those
blobs of painters tree. This here's where Monet really earns his accolades.
Trace the reflection of the tree in the water below the trunk waivers it's even
doubled against the leopard spot waves. We looked at earlier.
The canopy is reduced to dark green echoed the same lopsided circular pattern,
which becomes the spot since exacts.
This great diversity of brush strokes was something he encouraged other artists
to incorporate into their work.
You can almost imagine what this place sounds like heavy with the murmur of
conversation,
the splash of bathers and the clink of dishwasher balancing each other out the
late afternoon sun playing off the bushes on the distant shore.
The heat of the day now broken as friends recount the weekends adventures.
So now you see what a huge change this was from Della cross snake wrangling.
You can understand how brave Manet had to be in order to try and compete against
neoclassical. It looks incomplete. The brush strokes prominence,
and there's an overwhelming vagueness to it.
All neoclassical work feels impressive because this degree of precision requires
expensive tools and decades of training.
It's the visual equivalent to a palace and expression of wealth and mastery
impressionism rejects that impressionism tells us that our work matters because
it speaks to us and how we see the world, the institution doesn't get to decide.
What's beautiful.
We do this kind of rebellious streak resonated with the democracy, hungry French
Genes, changing money, had the resources to rent and then buy the home,
which would eventually become his world famous residence. By the mid 1890s,
he had converted a humble farmhouse into a cutting edge of state's complete its
greenhouse and skylight studio.
He hired seven gardeners now up in manage his two and a half acre garden issuing
daily instructions for the husbanding of his precious in any pads.
He wins to no small expense to import every color and variety of Lily pad that
he learns about encouraging them to create hybrid blossoms and rainbows of
Hugh's blue, yellow pinks that aged into a deep red.
He would have his gardeners over Windsor, the fragile tropical cultivars,
and especially like greenhouses, then replant them in his pond every spring.
So great. It was Monet's love of water lilies that you can trace a change.
In his perspective, when he first arrived at Shivani,
he would fix the horizon on his Japanese footbridge. But over time,
the gaze drops lower and lower until the only thing on the canvas is water and
Lily pads here he is in 1899,
mating 12 versions of Japanese footbridge fast-forward to 1916.
He started focusing on the shoreline areas with one of his weeping willows
printed out of concern for his son and countrymen fighting in world war one by
1919, he's all but abandoned.
The sky is nothing more than a blue contrast on upon the surface.
This is contemplative peace heavy with the burden of thoughts. At this point,
he had outlived both his eldest child, gene and his wife, Alice,
who passed away in 1914 and 1911,
respectively Alice's daughter blondish took over much of the day-to-day
management of the estate, inheriting that duty from her late husband, Jean,
if you're always in, out by the idea of step siblings getting married,
no Manet broke up a prior engagement between blush and one of his other
students. So that's.
[Inaudible].
As if he didn't have enough going wrong in his life.
It's during the same time that he begins at about cataracts through the mid 19
teens, up until he had corrective surgery in 1923,
his work began to develop a reddish Milky hue.
He responded by having his assistants,
prepare his colors for him rather than trusting his own perception for one who
loved color.
We can also imagine the immense psychological toll this must have had just
compared this example from 1907 to the rendition of his footbridge in 1920,
you can barely even make out the bridge. It's just a dock cage of red,
around a rock of red foliage.
Contrast that to these lilies that he finished in 1926.
And you can see the blues and greens returned to the forefront of his work.
There's a fair bit of scholarly study,
which suggests the operation likely gave Monet.
The ability to perceive ultraviolet light is a white blue globe.
People want to believe the great superhuman that is specialized side was what
allowed him to paint like you did.
But this has happened three years before his death of lung cancer on a list of
things that enables genius to flourish. Specialized rank far,
far below a partner who manages your domestic affairs for you.
[Inaudible].
Of women who sacrifice themselves in Monet.
We would be remiss not to mention the artistic talents of blanche Horshack Manet
as mentioned, the Porsche is where frequent patrons of my name,
meaning the blush has ready, grown up in an impressionist environments.
By the time I took her under his wing. In fact,
she also had started painting at the age of 11 and immediately took to the
impressionist style,
the two work so closely together on some pieces that it can be difficult for
experts to discern which hand created,
which work just combat her version of haystacks with a similar one.
From that series that sold at auction for all the money in the world,
sadly managing the family estate took up so much time that she stopped painting
for about 30 years.
She enabled money to focus totally on working through the last decades of his
life.
But what would blondish have produced if she was given that same measure of
support?
The opportunities women gave Monet came at a cost to themselves that lives and
their ambition.
What adds insult to injury is that the launch canvases may produced with Basha
support were underappreciated during my night's life,
even though museums would construct special wings just to display these massive
works of heartbreaking beauty side by side, as they were intended to be seen,
audiences were unmoved.
It wasn't as other 1950 it's thanks in large parts to the charitable estate
builds by blonch that the launch canvases were recognized for the immense works
of beauty that they were.
Then they died at the age of 86 in accordance with his wishes.
Only 50 of his closest friends attended one tore off the black around the coffin
and draped it,
and the floral printer fitting tributes for the color mad genius of the gardens.
So I really hope you found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and thank you for watching.